I am so inspired to see so many of you
here today so many old friends so many
new phrases it's going to be a really
wonderful day and I'm grateful for all
of you for journeying to be with us
today I want to recognize and thank the
leadership of the three AI Institute's
who are our partners in delivering the
pan-canadian AI strategy those who are
here with us today cam linky from ami
cam artis right over there
Stephan Letourneau from Nima I think
Stephan is here somewhere or will be
here shortly
and Garth Gibson I saw Arthur there's
Garth good morning Garth welcome I also
want to thank two of CFR's partners in
supporting artificial intelligence
research and training in Canada
these are Facebook and the RBC
Foundation and thanks to all of our
partners and all of you your support
means so much to me at CFR and we have
together come a long way in a very short
period of time today marks a very
special day for Canada and it all began
less than three years ago in 2017 CFR
was appointed by the Government of
Canada to develop and lead the
pan-canadian AI strategy the world's
first national a AI strategy working in
collaboration with Amy and Edmonton Mila
in Montreal and the vector Institute in
Toronto the strategy aims to maintain an
advanced Canada's position as one of the
world's leading AI nation's leading
research training and innovation the
strategy has four major goals first to
establish interconnected nodes of
scientific excellence in Edmonton
Montreal in Toronto to increase the
number of outstanding AI researchers and
skilled graduates in Canada to support a
national research community on AI that's
why we're here today and to develop
global thought leadership on the
economic ethical policy and legal
implications of advances in AI many of
Canada's successes in AI today are the
result of sustained long-term investment
in talented scientists who were pursuing
fundamental research to understand and
devel
approaches to machine learning that's
why as a core pillar of the pan-canadian
AI strategy we launched the Canada CFRA
I chairs program in partnership with Amy
Miele and the vector Institute the
program is critical to Canada's
investment in AI talent because it
provides researchers with dedicated
funding over five years to pursue the
same high-risk high-reward ideas that
resulted in Canada's early leadership in
AI a cornerstone of the pan-canadian AI
strategy a total of 86 and a half
million dollars has been allocated to
the candidacy for AI chairs program to
recruit and retain in Canada the best AI
researchers in the world in the past
year we have announced 46 Canada CF Rai
chairs exceptional researchers who are
advancing our understanding of machine
learning and training the next
generation of AI talent and today I am
very excited to announce the
appointments of 34 new Canada CFR AI
chairs bringing the total number to 80
I'd like to ask the 34 new Canada CIC
far ai chairs to stand and be recognized
thank you you can be seated to join in
our celebration this morning I'd like to
take a moment to share a video message
from the Honorable Navdeep Baines
minister of innovation Science and
Industry hello everyone I'm not debating
the minister of innovation Science and
Industry I'd like to congratulate the
researchers who are joining the kandacy
for AI chairs program this program
attracts the best researchers and
students to Canda and enhances our
international profile of AI research and
training by strengthening our leadership
and AI research in creating innovative
new technologies for growing our economy
creating highly skilled jobs and
improving the quality of life for all
Canadians congratulations once again
Thank You Minister Baines the 34 new
candidacy for AI chairs announced today
our pioneering research in areas that
will have global societal impact
including the development of machine
learning for medical image analysis and
robotics for surgery surgery 3d computer
vision new approaches to natural
language processing and explained
ability interpretability and fairness in
machine learning twenty one of the
chairs named in this cohort are they're
taking up their first faculty position
in Canada or have been recruited from
the US and around the world 13 of those
named today are staying in Canada to
continue to pursue their groundbreaking
research here all of the chairs that
we're announcing today are affiliated
with one of Canada's three national AI
Institute's Amy Miele and the vector
Institute they are all exceptional
researchers and experts in their fields
they come from universities all across
Canada they call Polytechnique to
Montreal McGill University université
laval university demony l université de
Sherbrooke University of Alberta
University of Toronto and the University
of Waterloo and many of them are working
closely with leading international
companies working in Canada to advance a
research in 2017 CFR forged a new
partnership with Facebook which provided
support to see far to help advance our
research and training programs in AI and
provide a dedicated support for two
additional AI chairs at miele today's
announcement marks an important
milestone in the partnership between CFR
and Facebook with the appointment by
Miele of siva reddy of mcgill university
Sivas right over here and pierre-luc
back home of the université de montréal
as our to Facebook CF Rai chairs Pierre
Luc are you here well give it there yes
we'll give the round of applause the
funding for the Facebook CF Rai chairs
is to enhance Canada's ability to
recruit and support rising star early
career academic researchers at Miele
the chairs will have no formal
relationship with Facebook and are both
brand new assistant professors who have
been recruited to Canada through the
chairs program we are grateful to
Facebook for their support thank you
today's announcement marks a critical
moment for Canada it demonstrates the
collaborative support of industry
academia and government working together
this type of collaboration is especially
unique to Canada and sends a strong
message to the rest of the world about
our country's vision for AI I believe
that collaboration will be key to
developing and implementing new aspects
of AI research and ensuring that we are
delivering positive social impact to
further support and facilitate
collaboration amongst Canadian AI
researchers and trainees I'm very
pleased to let you know that we will
launch a brand new CF Rai catalyst grant
program in January the program will
support new research collaborations with
and between our candidacy for AI chairs
preference will be given to proposals
that are multidisciplinary and/or
advanced training opportunities for
underrepresented groups so today is your
chance to hear from the new chairs and
start thinking about work that you would
like to undertake in collaboration with
any of our candidacy for AI chairs to
make sure that you get all the
information on this new AI catalyst
grants program you can sign up for our
e-newsletter
the a ICANN bulletin by going to the CFR
web page see Farsi a /i AI or watching
the web page itself for the call for
proposals that will be issued in January
and with that we are ready to kick off a
ICANN 2019 this is the second annual
meaning of the paying Canadian AI
strategy and we have a really exciting
day planned for you today's program is
designed to showcase the new candidacy
for AI chairs and the work that they're
doing to advance AI research and
training throughout the day we will
should be showcasing the chairs in panel
discussions across six research themes
and we'll have time at the end of each
panel discussion for questions from the
audience so we want to make sure that
you're engaged and active and thinking
about what questions you have for the
panelists we also have elements of the
program showcasing other aspects of the
pan-canadian AI strategy including a
poster competition for students and a
special keynote address on Rai and
society program over the lunch hour many
of our partners will have booths
showcasing the AI institutes and the
innovative training programs under the
CFR national AI for good training
program I invite you to visit the booths
and the posters over the lunch hour to
get a sense of the full breadth of
activity across the country it is going
to be a great day and so without further
ado let's get on with a ICANN 2019